2020 has been a year to forget for many
reasons
but it's that time of year so let's
reflect imagine you just blown
54 billion dollars it is more important
than ever for congress to find its
fiscal backbone
our debt puts at risk the long-term
solvency of major programs
such as social security and why to pay
for test tubes for cover tests
that turn out to be soda bottles to see
if hot tubbing a few times a week eases
stress
yeah those don't seem like good
investments
but us senator rand paul has published a
whole list
of all the things you can blow your hard
earned money on
and what washington apparently did spend
it on like
1.5 million dollars to give a couple of
reptiles some cardio
researchers spent a million and a half
taxpayer dollars
to get six lizards walk them on a
treadmill while taking
x-rays with 3d imaging technology and
then figure out how their joints moved
sure it's fascinating stuff maybe
for some but come on 1.5 million dollars
place your bets on how much it costs to
spray drunk rats
with bobcat urine just a tidy sum
of 4.5 million dollars
in all seriousness here's exactly what
the researchers did
in layman's terms they spent five weeks
giving rats
intermittent access to alcohol to get
them hooked
then they put the rats in a cage and
literally sprayed them with bobcat urine
a predator's odour to simulate trauma
then they tested whether males and
females
responded differently why that's
probably something you're wondering
right now
the answer research into ptsd and
alcoholism among war veterans
apparently someone has concluded that
surviving a gruesome war
is comparable to being sprayed with
urine so we've gone from paying people
to sit in hot tubs
to trying to get adults to watch less tv
and eat bucks
all of this money wasted and none of it
was initially washington's
this is 54 billion dollars of taxpayer
money
but hey look on the bright side at least
we can sleep well
now we know that a coke bottle is not a
good substitute for a test tube
the way the the united states government
has managed
its finances throughout this entire
thing is absolutely overall completely
abysmal
it's been nothing short of criminal
uh what the united states government has
done
throughout this entire pandemic there
were a few
okay things but overall the bad
outweighed the good by a whole lot
and it's really made the united states
government uh
out for exactly what it is which it is a
corporate coup
no one ever asked the question how are
you going to pay for it when it comes to
giving money to the pentagon or giving
money to weapons contractors or giving
money to
the oil and gas industry no one ever
asks how you're going to pay for it
but they ask how are you going to pay
for it when it comes to giving direct
relief to people then all of a sudden
they're worried about their pocketbook